nice to beef you the original Die Hard
actually came out 35 years ago yeah you
know I'm a big Bruce Willis fan I
believe he's one of the best actor
acting action stars of all time so it's
only right that I would parody uh
something after after what he built the
Synergy and energy between the delivery
between he and I uh what was the Synergy
well I mean two guys with amazing
physiques and amazing understanding of
how to kick ass I know she got your
shirt off quick in this
yeah
Kevin's action spoof Die Hard 2 Die
Harder is back for season two March 31st
on the Roku Channel this time we see Kev
trying so hard to pitch a movie starring
himself as the greatest action hero of
all time he doesn't realize he's become
a target of a Revenge plot that puts him
in real life danger you've been hit not
my blood
does that feel fake the first one of
course we had John Travolta and in this
one we got John Cena
how do you like your tea is the rock mad
that you've moved on to another wrestler
besides him no not yet but but
technically
I'm getting even because he went with
Ryan Reynolds we're worthwhile we're not
work-wise we're not any kind of why
that's a good point yeah so this is like
my shot back
you're doing a lot of things too
including your prank show with uh Nick
Cannon if you're going to get some
contestants that want to have
[Applause]
let's go you fooled the whole world a
lot of people thought that you really
were doing a show producing yourself
who's who's having mechanics baby yeah
I'm like what are these people doing a
lot of people who are some people you're
gonna prank uh my goodness we have
Fantasia
Lil Jon Ludacris was anybody mad after
you pranked absolutely absolutely was
there one that you were like we might be
taking it too far me with Nick I got
Nick on a couple more yeah I got Nick
again I spent some money on my pranks
with Nick I don't I don't go halfway I
do a full budget thanks Kev
foreign